hi my name is irene zhang i have been
here at microsoft research for about two
years and my focus is on next-generation
operating systems for the data center so
Microsoft you know used to make an
operating system I guess it still makes
an operating system but the kind of
operating systems that I'm talking about
today are not the ones that users
interact with but the ones that run
cloud services and applications that you
might go interact with so things like
Outlook or you know Bing and and other
services like that so what's driving
this change in operating systems in the
data center well there's been a large
trend with IO increasing in speed over
time and CPUs not so we have 100 gig
networks soon we'll have 200 gig and 400
gig networks we have storage now that we
can access within a matter of
microseconds not milliseconds and so all
of this means that your CPU has suddenly
become slower than your IO devices so
for operating systems people this is a
really big change in assumptions
operating systems in the past were
always designed with the assumption that
whenever you did i/o it was going to
take a long time in terms of what your
CPU saw so this is this change in sort
of hardware trends has really driven the
development of a new type of device
these are called kernel bypass devices
and what they do is they offload the
system stack mainly the operating system
and the hypervisor from the cpu to the
i/o device so by moving functionality
from the CPU and having the i/o device
perform that functionality instead we're
able to take more load off of the CPU
and have the i/o device which is faster
perform that instead so this is all
really great because it means that now
your application is able to run much
faster than it was before the problem
for application programmers is that
these devices while they eliminate the
operating system and hypervisor they
don't actually replace all of its
functionality
they replace simply the functionality
that's needed to skip the operating
system kernel but they don't do things
like provide a networking stack or a
file system and those are all things
that applications actually need to work
so this is a real problem and to make it
even worse different devices have
decided to offload different parts of
the operating system so what application
programmers have to do is actually
implement different types of operating
system functionality so they might have
to implement an entire networking stack
for some other types of devices they
have to implement a subset of the
existing operating system stack and then
for other devices those devices might
take care of the entire operating system
so the application doesn't have to make
any changes at all so this is a real
problem for application programmers
because they're left doing something
that's really complicated and it doesn't
work with all of the devices in the data
center so the research that I've been
doing recently has been thinking about
how to make these kernel bypass devices
easier for application programmers to
use and the key insight here is that
just because we're bypassing the
operating system kernel doesn't mean we
have to bypass all of that operating
system functionality and as well instead
what we can do is use something called a
library operating system which runs in
the same address space as the
application to actually get a lot of the
benefits of the operating system without
the overhead of the operating system
kernel so a library operating system
offers another benefit which is the
ability to have flexibility so you can
link in different types of library
operating systems into your application
in the past this was always used to
support different types of applications
but today with a new operating system
architecture that I've been developing
called the deme kernel we're actually
able to use this to support different
kinds of devices so we can have one that
supports that has an entire networking
stack in it or we can have one that has
just a subset of the networking stack
required to use other kinds kinds of
devices or we
you just have a very thin translation
layer so all of this means that the
application programmer is able to use a
single standardized operating system
interface but still you take take
advantage of these different types of
kernel bypass devices so the operating
system that I talked about today is
available online if you'd like to take a
look at it it's on github or you can
find the link from my website which is
probably easier to remember Thanks
[Applause]
you